des intempéries d'une violence
exceptionnelle ont frappé ces derniers
jours plusieurs départements de notre
pays
je souhaite exprimer à nos concitoyens
la solidarité de la représentation
nationale tout particulièrement aux
habitants des alpes-maritimes
département particulièrement meurtri par
cette catastrophe
nos pensées accompagnent les victimes
ainsi que leur famille dans ces moments
douloureux
je sais que le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour apporter toute
l'aide nécessaire aux départements
touchés dès demain le président de la
république se rendra dans les alpes
maritimes
je souhaite également salué en votre nom
le travail exemplaire des équipes de
secours auquel s'est jointe l'armée et
l'engagement sans faille sur le terrain
des agents des services publics et des
élus locaux
nos collègues députés ont été touchées
par ce drame et en déployer eux-mêmes
beaucoup d'efforts ces derniers jours à
tous nos collègues je veux dire ici et
au nom de vous tous notre soutien à
marine brenier bernard brochand eric
ciotti loïc dombreval eric pauget
cédric roussel michèle tabarot laurence
trastour isnard et alexandra valletta
ardisson
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur eric ciotti
merci monsieur le président j'associe à
ma question la députée marine brenier
mais je crois pouvoir le faire aussi
pour tous les députés des alpes
maritimes
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre le département des
alpes-maritimes vous l'avez dit monsieur
le président et je suis très sensible à
votre témoignage actuel est celui que
vous m'avez adressé ce week end a subi
un choc terrible
la montagne des alpes-maritimes a été
touché au coeur les villages de nos
vallées 1 subi un véritable traumatisme
équipements publics détruits cimetière
emporté maison rayés de la carte
86 maisons disparues sur la commune de
saint martin vésubie victimes
actuellement encore en cours de
recherche
monsieur le premier ministre vous êtes
venu sur place et je vous en remercie
l'état a été au rendez vous au
rendez-vous de la réactivité et de
l'efficacité
je veux remercier très sincèrement tous
les services placés sous votre autorité
bien sûr les militaires de la
gendarmerie les militaires de l'armée
que vous avez des péchés je veux
remercier nos sapeurs pompiers qui ont
été admirables de courage dans la nuit
tragique de vendredi à samedi
je pense en cet instant au capitaine
colibert et aux sapeurs pompiers
volontaires du centre de secours de
saint martin vésubie loïc milo qui ont
disparu et qui à ce jour ne sont
toujours pas retrouvé alors ce choc
monsieur le premier ministre il faudra
s'en relever et c'est un véritable appel
au secours que je lance un appel à la
solidarité nationale
la volonté doit réparer l'injustice de
la force des éléments les estimations
les plus sommaires considère qu'il
faudra au moins un milliard et demi
d'euros pour réparer les infrastructures
des dizaines de ponts ont été arrachés
des dizaines voire des centaines de
kilomètres de routes des infrastructures
alors oui nous avons besoin de vous nous
avons besoin de cette solidarité et nous
lançons cet appel à l'engagement de la
nation pour ces communes
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député eric ciotti
ce week end vous l'avez dit nous l'avons
toutes et tous vu les alpes-maritimes
ont en effet été touché par un épisode
climatique absolument hors norme
j'ai d'abord une pensée pour les
familles endeuillées
ces familles dans la tente de nouvelles
de leurs proches
ces familles qui ont tout perdu ces
familles qu'avec vous du reste j'ai
rencontré samedi et qui m'ont
impressionné par leur esprit de
résilience et de solidarité ce que j'ai
vu avec le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin ce que nous avons vu de
détresse et je le dis de désolation nous
ont considérablement touché le bilan
humain
au moment où je m'exprime n'est pas
encore connue mais il est d'ores et déjà
très lourd quatre décès des huit
personnes disparues treize supposé
disparu dont on est sans nouvelles alors
on nous parlons de nombreux acteurs
forces de secours militaires de la
gendarmerie et des armes et personnels
civils continuent de s'activer au profit
des populations sinistrées
je voudrais à mon tour et au nom du
gouvernement de la république rendre
hommage à l'ensemble de ces femmes et de
ces hommes dans la crise
sous l'autorité du préfet des alpes
maritimes
vous avez bien voulu monsieur le député
souligner le dévouement et l'engagement
sans faille de l'état
je voudrais à mon tour souligné celui
des collectivités territoriales des
associations et de l'ensemble de la
population qui se sont mobilisés avec
dévouement et dans un esprit de
coordination exemple est un complément
en complément mesdames et messieurs les
députés des 550 sapeurs-pompiers
départementaux 200 sapeurs pompiers de
la région de saint sauveur sauveteurs de
brignoles et de nogent le rotrou plus de
500 gendarmes des militaires pour
déblayer et ouvrir les axes notamment du
1er régiment étranger de génie pour
assurer les missions de transport et de
secours à la personne une flotte de 13
hélicoptères quatre hélicoptères lourds
des armes et 6 de la sécurité civile et
3 de la gendarmerie ont été
immédiatement mobilisées par mes soins
pour assurer les secours à personne
l'acheminement des vivres d'eau de
matériel dont des groupes électrogènes
66 ont été déployés en un temps record
et des téléphones satellitaires 55
communes sont plus particulièrement
touchées et concentrent les actions des
pouvoirs publics dans les vallée de la
tinée de la vésubie et de la rouille a
soit environ 12000 personnes dont 700
d'ores et déjà accueilli à l'hôtel ou en
centres d'hébergement
les opérations de secours ont concerné
au total plus de 1600 personnes
certaines secouru par les airs et plus
de 760 interventions assurées à terre
alors que la mobilisation demeure sur le
terrain nous sommes toujours dans le
temps du secours de l'aide aux sinistrés
le temps de la reconstruction c'est
monsieur le député d'ores et déjà mis en
place les différents ministères sont
mobilisés
et pour organiser le soutien aux
victimes de la population et reconstruit
remettre en état de fonctionnement les
réseaux eau électricité téléphone ainsi
que des infrastructures routières
le président de la république vous
l'avez dit monsieur le président se
rendra lui même sur place demain pour
constater cela ait affirmé
la très forte mobilisation de l'état qui
sait vous l'avez reconnu mobilisés dès
le début et qui ne faillira pas je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur loïc dombreval
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
j'associe à cette question mais collègue
député des alpes-maritimes et en
particulier cédric roussel et alexandre
aval et ardisson qui est resté dans sa
circonscription particulièrement touchés
pour aider la population
je veux associer également le député
denis masseglia mouna ici à mes côtés
originaire de braille sur roya est resté
sans nouvelles de sa famille pendant
quatre jours le département des alpes
maritimes a subie le 10 octobre dernier
un épisode climatique dévastateur jamais
vu depuis l'installation des instruments
de mesure vous êtes immédiatement rendu
sur place accompagné du ministre de
l'intérieur pour annoncer des mesures
attendues est exprimé la solidarité de
la nation le président de la république
sera présent demain je vous en remercie
j'exprime avant tout ma compassion
fraternel aux proches des victimes et
aux sinistrés
la préfecture des alpes maritimes qui
avaient pris toutes les dispositions
nécessaires en amont est plus que jamais
au travail
rendons encore un hommage appuyé à nos
pompiers à nos gendarmes à nos
militaires à me policiers mais aussi à
la générosité de nos bénévoles de nos
entreprises et de toute la population
des alpes-maritimes
saluons également les extraordinaires
maires et élus locaux
les agents de l'état des collectivités
territoriales mobiliser de toutes leurs
forces sur le terrain
aux côtés des sinistrés les
alpes-maritimes est l'un des rares
départements français exposés à
quasiment tous les risques naturels
avalanche feux de forêt inondation
tempête mouvements de terrains canicules
séisme risques littoraux en seulement 40
ans certaines communes du département
ont été reconnues en état de catastrophe
naturelle à plus de 40 reprise demain
l'état de catastrophe naturelle sera
déclaré par le conseil des ministres
monsieur le ministre vous le savez et
vous l'avez constaté le département des
alpes-maritimes souffre la fréquence des
sinistres l'importance des dégâts subis
mais aussi la diversité des risques
encourus par notre territoire appelle un
traitement différencié
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire maintenant au delà de la réponse
immédiate et adaptez vous avez su
apporter parfaitement pour prévenir une
énième catastrophe
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
de parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député dombreval à travers votre
intervention qui fait suite à celle de
votre collègue ciotti je veux souligner
devant la représentation nationale
la forte mobilisation des élus de
terrain et en particulier des
représentants ici dans cette assemblée
des alpes-maritimes que j'ai vues
extrêmement à pied d'oeuvre dès les
premières heures de cette catastrophe
épouvantable ainsi que je les dis alors
que l'heure est toujours aux secours à
la recherche des victimes et à la
dispensation des secours immédiats
l'état entend continuer et amplifier
autant que nécessaire
sa contribution à l'accomplissement de
ses missions mais vous avez parfaitement
raison
nous devons d'ores et déjà anticipé la
suite je vous confirme que le conseil
des ministres déclarera demain dans les
territoires concernés
l'état de catastrophe naturelle par
ailleurs
les procédures prévues en pareille
circonstance pour que la solidarité
nationale s'exerce en direction des
collectivités territoriales dans les
infrastructures essentielles vital comme
cela a été rappelé ont été endommagés
ces procédures ont déjà été engagés afin
que les rapports d'expertisé
correspondant me soit produit dans les
meilleurs délais et que nous puissions
mobiliser les fonds nécessaires à la
reconstruction
il est en effet à craindre que les
volumes des dégâts soit estimé dans des
proportions tout à fait significatives
il n'est donc pas question que seules
les collectivités territoriales impact
est un supporter les conséquences sur ce
registre comme sur les autres l'état
monsieur le député sera au rendez vous
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à madame la présidente
valérie rabault merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
ce qui s'est passé hier soir au conseil
d'administration d' angie est une honte
c'est une honte car pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de notre pays
l'état première actionnaire d'une
entreprise fleuron industriel
autrefois public a été mis en minorité
par le conseil d'administration d' angie
pensez vous que quiconque aurait osé
faire subir une telle humiliation
général de gaulle à georges pompidou à
françois mitterrand avec ce conseil
d'administration c'est l'état qui a été
humiliée et donc nous toutes et tous
alors monsieur le premier ministre
aujourd'hui c'est vous qui portez la
responsabilité avec le avec le président
de la république de faire en sorte que
l'état soit respectée faire respecter
l'état s'est donné une ligne claire sur
la stratégie d'un groupe industriel dont
il est le premier actionnaire
vous avez dit soutenir l'opération
veolia votre ministre de l'économie et
des finances a
le contraire faire respecter l'état
c'est protéger l'argent des français
maîtres des contreparties au soutien
qu'ils donnent aujourd'hui monsieur le
premier ministre vous êtes moins disant
que le gouvernement libéral des pays bas
qui demande que des contreparties soient
proposées lorsqu'il donne son soutien
faire respecter l'état c'est empêcher
les démantèlements à l'oeuvre au pas y
aller par certains grands groupes
internationaux comme par exemple ce que
nous craignons aujourd'hui avec
honeywell à l'usiné de laguépie
je vous demande donc une seule chose
monsieur le premier ministre fait
respecter l'état par cette frange du
capitalisme qui ne vous respecte plus
merci vers le présidente monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la
présidente valérie rabault dans cette
affaire comme dans les autres l'état à
veiller au respect de ses intérêts et de
ceux des contribuables
il a exprimé il a exprimé par son vote
au conseil d'administration d' angie la
position qui est toujours la sienne
depuis le début de ce dossier à savoir à
savoir
il s'agit d'une opération d'entreprise
pour laquelle nous demandons et nous
continuerons à y veiller
premièrement mesdames et messieurs les
députés la sauvegarde de l'emploi
deuxièmement la sauvegarde d'une logique
industrielle ainsi que l'a rappelé le
ministre chargé de l'économie de façon
constante
troisièmement le respect des règles de
concurrence pour le marché de l'eau et
de l'assainissement dans les
collectivités territoriales
quatrièmement quatrièmement le respect
des règles de souveraineté pour que ce
segment demeure ce segment stratégique
demeure sous pavillon
nationale je rappelle à l'assemblée
nationale qu'à ce jour la seule offre la
seule offre qui se soit présentée est
celle et vous le savez de veolia c'est
précisément parce que nous avons par la
voix du ministre bruno lemaire demandé à
ce que sur ces quatre principes les
discussions soit approfondie que nous
n'avons pas voté favorablement hier soir
au conseil d'administration à la
solution actuellement en cours nous
demandons à ce que ces discussions se
poursuivent pour atteindre le respect
claire et nette des objectifs que nous
avons fixés
merci monsieur le premier ministre
merci monsieur le premier ministre vous
avez exprimé une position l'état était
mis en minorité monsieur le premier
ministre c'est une première dans
l'histoire de la vème république
ça n'est jamais arrivé se faire
respecter
ce faire respecter passe par des actes
vous auriez pu être monsieur le premier
ministre dire entrer au capital de suez
si vous aviez voulu là vous auriez créer
un rapporteur si ma présidence rapport
de la parole à monsieur eric coquerel
monsieur le premier ministre la france
est malade c'est pas la 10e propagent
cette maladie c'est la misère la france
66 millions d'habitants comptera à la
fin de l'année 10 millions de pauvres 8
millions de français vont chercher la
boule au ventre une aide alimentaire
nous n'avons jamais vécu une situation
pareille depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale nous dînons secours populaire
une responsable de médecins nous nous on
nous a dit qu'elle a dû gérer une
situation en seine-saint-denis
comparable à celle des pays pauvres
je veux rendre hommage à ces
associations familles aussi qui
combattent sol l'épidémie de misère qui
ronge le pays seuls parce que l'état
n'est plus là le président est parti en
guerre contre un virus paraît-il mais il
a capitulé face à la misère
non vous n'êtes plus à moins d'un pour
cent des 100 milliards d'euros du plan
de relance sont consacrés au soutien aux
personnes pauvres et précaires
il aurait pourtant suffi de 7 milliards
d'euros pour éradiquer la grande
pauvreté pour que la solidarité ne soit
pas qu'un mot aussi je vous demande de
vous positionner face aux premières
mesures concrètes que je vais vous
présenter
je pense à notre jeunesse à genoux pour
qu'elle puisse rester de bourg pour
ouvrir le rsa aux 18-25 ans ou recruter
300 mille emplois jeunes au smic dans
une société solidaire
la gratuité des premiers mètres cubes
d'eau de l'électricité du gaz ne serait
pas un cadeau mais une juste mesure
contre la misère dans une société
solidaire annuler la réforme de
l'assurance chômage augmente et les
minima sociaux et automatiser leur verso
ne serait pas une faveur mais une juste
mesure contre la pauvreté collègues
écoutez la voix de nos anciens c'était
il ya 170 ans victor hugo était là sur
les mêmes bancs que nous il disait je ne
suis pas de ceux qui croient qu'on peut
supprimer la souffrance en ce monde mais
je suis de ceux qui pensent et qui
affirme qu'on peut détruire la misère
collègues il n'y a pas besoin de
décréter la guerre à la misère pourrait
indiquer cette lèpre simplement tendre
la main
alors à ceux et celles qui se taisent
qui se cachent sous leur capuche dans la
file attentes alimentaire je dis n'ayez
pas honte de revendiquer la solidarité
je demande au ministre des solidarités
et de la santé monsieur le député vous
avez raison la période des derniers mois
avec l'épidémie le confinement a eu un
impact sur de nombreux ménages français
il est factuel de dire qu'il y à une
augmentation du nombre de familles qui
relèvent de l'aide alimentaire de notre
pays
il est factuel de dire qu'un certain
nombre de français n'ont pas pu joindre
les deux bouts faute de pouvoir réaliser
le complément de salaire qu'il est qui
étaient parfois de l'heure et que de
nombreuses familles qui ne pouvait plus
se rendre dans les supermarchés bon
marché au fait les courses dans leur
quartier ont vu leurs dépenses du
quotidien augmenté monsieur le député le
gouvernement n'a pas été inactif loin
s'en faut pendant cette période
l'aide exceptionnelle de solidarité qui
étaient attribués à des millions de
familles l'aide alimentaire qui a été
augmentée pour des millions de familles
comme jamais d'ailleurs elle n'avait été
attribué
et à ce niveau là dans notre pays
l'augmentation de l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire de 100 euros par enfant
lors de la rentrée précédente le soutien
exceptionnel et sans précédent de 100
millions d'euros pour l'ensemble des
associations dans le cadre de l'aide
alimentaire
j'ai moi même installée il ya quinze
jours monsieur le député le comité de
lutte de coordination de l'ensemble des
associations impliquées dans la lutte
contre le club dans le soutien à l'aide
alimentaire ainsi que le conseil
national que ça paie le cnl sous la
responsabilité de la députée fiona
lazare il y a dix jours le premier
ministre a reçu pendant plus de trois
heures
l'ensemble des associations qui luttent
dans le champ des solidarités il ya
quelques jours pour faire le point sur
la stratégie de pauvreté et leur
annoncer qu'il y aura bientôt des
mesures supplémentaires pour venir en
aide aux familles le plus pauvre
monsieur le député je ne partage pas
avec vous votre vision du plan de
relance
d'abord parce qu'il ya des sommes
considérables inédites qui seront
déployés en faveur des plus précaires et
des plus fragiles de notre pays
ensuite monsieur le député parce que la
première solidarité dans notre pays
c'est l'emploi la première source de
sortie la misère c'est l'emploi
la première raison d'entrer dans la
pauvreté c'est le chômage et lorsque
vous mettez des milliards sur la table
pour aider les entreprises à embaucher
des jeunes
lorsque vous éviter que les seniors des
entreprises perdent leur emploi alors
qu'on sait qu'ils ne retrouveront pas
vous fais de la politique de solidarité
active et efficace et 1to monsieur le
député et c'est l'action résolue du
gouvernement depuis des mois et pour les
mois à venir merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame échelle creuser
merci monsieur le vice de la justice je
veux en préambule vous assurer de toute
ma confiance ainsi que celle d'un bon
nombre de mes collègues
toutefois la confiance n'exclut pas le
contrôle ces derniers temps quelques
magistrats vous prête des volontés sur
les bases de supputations et il est bon
ton de rappeler ici que l'on ne juge pas
sur des mesures hypothétique mais bien
sur du concret vous avez indiqué
monsieur le garde des sceaux lors de vos
différentes prises de parole vouloir une
justice de proximité et une
réconciliation entre les français et
leur justice
voilà des volontés que l'on peut
qu'approuver et dont on ne peut que se
réjouir aujourd'hui malheureusement
force est de constater que la réalité
est tout autre dans nos territoires et
en particulier dans les territoires
ruraux
j'ai un exemple concret dans ma
circonscription en juin dernier les
auditeurs de justice ont dû choisir leur
affectation pour une prise de fonction
en septembre 2000
oubli ou volonté aucun poste de juge
d'instruction n'a été ouvert pour le
tribunal judiciaire de sens
seul un juge judiciaire il a été affecté
par conséquent la dj direction n'a plus
de magistrats instructeurs et son
président sera amené à confié par
délégation
la compétence de juge d'instruction au
juge judiciaire
vous le savez cette organisation ne
renforce ni la justice de proximité ni
la justice de la confiance
il sera en effet très compliqué pour ce
magistrat d'investiguer qualitativement
les affaires compte tenu des autres
prérogatives aussi un magistrat
instructeur entretient des liens étroits
avec les enquêteurs ces liens risque là
encore d'être distendus et ainsi rendre
la résolution des affaires plus
complexes
par ailleurs et c'est pour moi un point
essentiel la délégation dont bénéficiera
le dit juge ne revêt pas les mêmes
garanties qu'un magistrat instructeur je
parle ici de l'inamovibilité ce un
tribunal sans cabinet d'instruction ne
correspond pas aux ambitions affichées
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre que
pensez vous faire concrètement et
rapidement concernant la situation du
tribunal de sens et pouvez vous vous
engagez devant la représentant national
à ne pas pardonnez moi l'expression
vider nos jus direction de proximité
afin que ces dernières restent
opérationnels merci merci la parole est
un monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
creuser et mais la justice c'est d'abord
la défendre pendant l'été meurtrier par
exemple mais c'est être intransigeant
quand elles disent fonctionne et c'est
aussi lui donner les moyens d'agir
je suis fier de vous indiquer que si
vous le voulez bien
la justice sera dotée d'un budget
historique plus lui pour cent merci
monsieur le premier ministre pour cette
écoute attentive
c'est la hausse la plus forte depuis un
quart de siècle 607 millions qui vont
être répartis entre la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
l'administration pénitentiaire et les
juridictions 2450 recrutement madame la
députée 750 à recruter dès maintenant
764 pour renforcer la justice dès le 1er
janvier
aider les magistrats et je peux vous
assurer que les services du ministère de
la justice sont d'ores et déjà au
travail pour les renforts obtenus afin
qu'il soit opérationnel dès janvier j'ai
rencontré ce matin l'ensemble des
procureurs généraux
concrètement cela signifie que chaque
juridiction de chaque territoire va
recevoir des moyens humains
s'agissant du tribunal qui me préoccupe
celui de sens sans attendre je vous
indique que trois personnels
supplémentaires
un juriste assistant de renfort de greef
vont venir compléter votre juridiction
csssae mais la justice de notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre
s'il vous plaît la parole est à madame
karine le bon ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
la crise sanitaire que nous subissons a
mis en évidence l'urgence de développer
les productions locales dans les
secteurs stratégiques dans cette
nouvelle cartographie la sécurité
alimentaire occupe une place centrale
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de petits
territoires insulaires
cette évidence est largement admise mais
la commission européenne vient de donner
un signal inquiétant
en dépit des engagements successifs des
commissaires à l'agriculture
et malgré le vote du parlement européen
la commission a décidé ces jours-ci de
diminuer le budget du posei qui je le
rappelle est la déclinaison de la pac
pour les régions dites
ultrapériphériques les aides directes à
destination des agriculteurs des régions
d'outre-mer serait ainsi amputé de 77
millions d'euros pour la période 2021 et
2027 d'au moins 25 millions pour la
réunion
cette diminution est une exception
puisque dans le même temps l'enveloppent
française de la pac est elle maintenue
et préserver pour quelles raisons les
territoires les plus pauvres devrait-il
de surcroît être ainsi pénalisés ce
paradoxe est incompréhensible et très
mal vécu par nos agriculteurs et
l'ensemble de nos filières agro
industriel si elle devait se confirmer
la position de la commission aggraverait
la situation actuelle où les fonds posée
y sont déjà insuffisants et doivent être
complétés par des aides nationales pire
l'autosuffisance alimentaire de nos
territoires qui est désormais un
objectif partagé par tous seraient
durablement compromise
monsieur le ministre quelles initiatives
comptez vous prendre en liaison avec
l'espagne et le portugal pour que l'
enveloppe du posei soit au moins
maintenue à son niveau actuel
merci la parole la parole est à monsieur
julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée karine le bond
d'abord permettez moi de vous féliciter
pour votre élection et pour votre
première prise de parole je crois et
permettez moi également de saluer madame
la députée huguette bello qui a fait
tant et tant de travail en faveur de nos
territoires ultramarins vous avez raison
et je le dis clairement nous ne
laisserons pas tomber les territoires
ultramarins vis-à-vis de cette décision
qui n'est pas acceptable de la
commission de réduire le montant du
posei alors pour celles et ceux qui ne
le connaissent pas le posei c'est un
fond extrêmement important c'est près de
280 millions d'euros qui permet d'aller
financé sur nos territoires ultramarins
des projets d'alimentation et des
projets agroalimentaires et agriculture
eau c'est essentiel or aujourd'hui la
commission européenne a prévu une
diminution de près de 4% vous l'avez
très bien dit madame la députée de ces
fonds dédié aux territoires ultramarins
que soient français ou européens
ça n'est pas acceptable et donc qu'est
ce que nous faisons nous allons tous
nous mobiliser c'est ce que nous avons
commencé et y compris la représentation
nationale qui il ya encore quelques
jours rencontrer le commissaire européen
à l'agriculture pour leur faire part de
ses préoccupations
ces trois choses que nous faisons en
lien avec le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes clément bonne et le
ministre d outre-mer sébastien lecornu
la première chose c'est qu'on mobilise
les autres pays européens j'étais il ya
quelques jours à bruxelles avec
l'espagne le portugal et la grèce
nous poussons d'une même voix
deuxièmement ce que nous faisons c'est
que nous disons à la commission
européenne vous savez la proposition
financière que vous faites aujourd'hui
sur le posei elle ne tient pas compte de
l'augmentation extraordinaire du budget
de la pac obtenu par le président la
république par clément bonne lors du
dernier conseil des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement et donc nous demandons à ce
que ce soit pris à sa juste valeur enfin
pape aujourd'hui même nous adressons un
courrier sébastien lecornu clément bonne
et moi même au commissaire européen
pour faire en sorte que cette voie
européenne elles soient entendues au
bénéfice de nos territoires ultramarins
vous avez raison merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur bernard perrut
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur depuis plusieurs
jours les sapeurs pompiers dans le sud
de la france portent secours à nos
concitoyens et mobilise toutes leurs
forces pour faire face avec courage à
cette situation climatique exceptionnel
nous saluons bien évidemment leurs
actions au péril de leur vie
mais au même moment d'autres sapeurs
pompiers dans le rhône régulièrement
victimes de violence ont subi de
nouvelle agression et l'un d'entre eux a
même été blessé à quelques pas de sa
caserne par un individu armé d'une
hachette à rillieux la pape comme une
pourtant très investis contre la
sécurité
une nouvelle étape a été franchie avec
une dizaine de voitures incendiées dans
l'une projetées contre la façade de
l'église cible d'un acte criminel
mené par un commando de personnes vêtues
de noir et cagoulés
nos soldats du feu et leurs véhicules
ont été caillassés
c'est intolérable et s'attaquaient une
église comme à tous lieux de culte est
absolument inqualifiable
face à de tels actes révoltants quelles
réponses concrètes apportées vous pour
lutter contre ces violences urbaines qui
se multiplient
combien d'effectifs supplémentaires vont
être déployés sur la métropole de lyon
et le rhône pour ramener le calme
rassurer nos concitoyens qui ont peur
soutenir nos forces de sécurité et de
secours qui sont lcd quels pouvoirs et
moyens allez vous donner aux maires
déterminés à agir qui vous sollicitent
car ils sont confrontés chaque jour à
des actes qui mettent à mal lors de
républicains l'état ne pourra se faire
respecter
que si vous exprimer devant nous
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
miné de l'intérieur
la fermeté fermeté dans l'action fermeté
dans la répression fermeté dans la
sanction
il en va de la rue de l'avenir de la
france
merci monsieur débuté la parole et à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur je suis le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député peru hier je me suis
rendu à rillieux-la-pape pour apporter
mon soutien d'abord aux catholiques de
france puisque cette église en effet a
été attaqué par une voiture dont une a
mis le feu ne se sont tout à fait
conscientes les caméras de vidéo
protection installées par la mairie le
démontre avec des hommes cagoulés qui
s'en sont pris vous avez raison aux
pompiers aux forces de l'ordre et à ce
symbole évidemment éminemment important
pour la commune de rieux et j'ai apporté
aux députés à la députée pardon au maire
et à l'ensemble de la communauté des
forces de l'ordre et des pompiers un
soutien évidemment la nation toute
entière est une demande très
particulière effectivement pour que les
moyens de police soient mis pour gros
trouve ces personnes qu'on les confonde
devant la justice et nous l'espérons
qu'il soit condamné dire monsieur peru
que je souhaite en effet mettre des
effectifs supplémentaires à la demande
du premier ministre les grandes
agglomérations et singulièrement à lyon
dont le maire m'a écrit mais doit aussi
les parlementaires quel que soit leur
bord m'ont interpellé parce qu'il manque
des effectifs dans la libération
lyonnaise et je suis très heureux d'être
un ministre de l'intérieur qui créent
des effectifs supplémentaires que nous
pourrons à partir de cette année envoyé
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur le
fait qu'une proposition de loi c'est le
député déposée par mme duflot verts et
banham tueur ou ce sera à l'ordre du
jour le 18 novembre à l'assemblée
nationale et j'espère que vous voterez
comme un seul homme les propositions du
groupe de la république en marche pour
donner davantage de moyens aux polices
municipales dont j'ai dit à monsieur le
maire de rillieux la pape qu'il serait
l'une des personnes qui pour l
expérimenté en effet et notamment en
renforçant les moyens de ces polices
avec ces mères qui sont courageux comme
vous l'avez souligné
enfin dans la proposition de loi de
monsieur matras encore un parlementaire
de la majorité
nous aurons l'occasion de souligner de
souligner davantage le grand effort de
sapeurs pompiers de france notamment en
donnant les moyens de vidéo protection
sur eux mêmes
meira piétons et sur leur véhicule pour
les protéger et pour enfin les condamnés
quand nous aurons l'épreuve merci
monsieur le ministre la parole de
monsieur christophe naegelen merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chargée de l'autonomie on ne peut que
déplorer que nous soignants de la
fonction publique territoriale soit
oubliée de la politique actuelle en
effet en plus de devoir passer des
concours régionaux sur titres qui n'ont
rien à voir avec leur métier d'avoir un
nombre de postes ouverts en totale
inadéquation avec le nombre de postes
vacants entravant ainsi la
titularisation est la fidélisation des
agents ils sont l'objet d'une forte
discrimination salariale avec des
différences de salaires d'environ 350
euros pour une infirmière titulaire et
jusqu'à 450 euros par mois pour les
auxiliaires de soins
ces inepties créer un cercle vicieux de
travail dégradées qui entraîne une
véritable hémorragie des personnels dans
les ehpad de la fonction publique
territoriale
madame la ministre deux questions
simples que comptez vous faire pour
simplifier l'accès aux métiers de la
santé dans la fonction publique
territoriale afin de la rendre plus
attractive et d'en revaloriser les
salaires et plus largement
juste pour finir je voudrais vous
interpeller sur les autres oubliés du
ségur que sont les siad et les
professionnels du secteur du handicap
que comptez vous faire pour les
rémunérer enfin à hauteur de leur
engagement
merci j'ai débuté la porte et madame
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué
chargé de l'autonomie merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député christophe
nager l'aisne vous m'interrogez sur la
différence de traitement dans les ehpad
entre personnels fonction publique
territoriale et fonction publique
hospitalière et je vous en remercie
votre question me permet de saluer
l'engagement au quotidien de ces
personnels pour les résidents en ehpad
est bien sûr encore plus au sein de
cette crise sanitaire
le plan hôpital présenté l'an passé par
mme agnès buzyn était la première brique
d'un investissement massif de l'état en
faveur de la revalorisation de ses
métiers comme vous le savez ce plan
prévoyait la création d'une prime
grattage à destination des infirmiers
des aides soignants et des aides médico
psychologiques dans les établissements
publics
cette prime a vu le jour au 1er janvier
2020 à destination des personnels de la
fonction publique hospitalière a été
versée à date nous étions en attente des
textes pour la fonction publique
territoriale
j'ai le plaisir de vous informer que
tous les textes sont désormais publiés
la prime grattage viendra donc compléter
la paix de tous les agents de la
fonction publique territoriale dès le
mois de novembre
la revalorisation est très substantiel
110 euros par mois en moyenne à cette
revalorisation s'ajoute celle du ségur
180 euros par mois au total
nous sommes donc sur un 13e et un 14e
mois pour ses agents l'état est donc au
rendez vous de l'appel des agents des
ehpad publics
j'aurais prochainement l'occasion de
présenter dans le cadre du plan métiers
du laroque de l'autonomie d'autres
mesures en faveur des salariés de la
famille du grand âge qu'il soit à
domicile ou en établissement nous leur
devons beaucoup à nous de leur apporter
la reconnaissance qu'il mérite
merci merci ministre le siège de député
merci madame la ministre pour votre
réponse
vous parlez de briquettes en effet en
effet c'est une première brique assez
intéressante mais qui ne suffit pas par
rapport au mur qui sépare les
fonctionnaires de la fonction publique
territoriale des autres et je pense
notamment aux au concours et je regrette
aussi la non réponse sur les
professionnels du secteur du handicap et
du ciad qui malheureusement ont été
largement oubliée et qui ont besoin
aussi de réponses concrètes
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame jeanine dubié
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre la situation est désormais
critique dans les établissements et
services pour personnes âgées de
nombreux professionnels du soin et de
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
sorte épuisé et décourager de la
première vague de l'épidémie de kobe 19
entraînant de nombreux arrêts maladie
voire des démissions cela ne fait
qu'aggraver la situation déjà difficile
que rencontre le secteur médico social
en matière de recrutement depuis de
nombreuses années aujourd'hui près de
deux tiers des ehpad ont un poste non
pourvu depuis plus de six mois notamment
chez les ex oriente les agences
d'intérim ne parviennent plus à répondre
à l'ensemble des demandes bien sûr les
revalorisations salariales annoncées à
l'issue du ségur de la santé ainsi que
les primes et grant agéco vite sont un
premier pas pour rendre ce métier plus
attractives mais encore faudrait-il
qu'elle soit versée de manière équitable
et rapide à tous les professionnels du
comptage quel que soit le type de
structure qui les emploie et je n'oublie
pas le secteur de l'aide à domicile ou
la prime covit tarder à être versée
monsieur le ministre la est loin d'être
suffisant a situation critique
réponse immédiate d'une part pouvez vous
vous engagez engagé une campagne de
promotion de la réserve sanitaire afin
de faire connaître et renforcer ce
vivier de professionnels volontaires et
mobilisable par l'état d'autre part
pouvez vous engager vous engagez à
lancer un plan massif de formation sur
les métiers du grand âge afin de
permettre aux établissements les
services de pourvoir les postes vacants
vous présenterez demain le plfss pour
2021 en conseil des ministres avez vous
prévu les crédits nécessaires
voilà maintenant deux ans que le
gouvernement mène concertation sur
concertation sur le sujet de l'autonomie
nos étagères sont remplies de rapports
nos têtes pleines de propositions alors
pouvez-vous nous assurer que le laroque
de l'autonomie ne sera pas moyen de plus
pour retarder le tant attendu projet de
loi grandes pages économie chevaux
madame brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué chargé de l'autonomie monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée jeanine dubié
votre question me donne l'opportunité de
revenir sur la politique que nous menons
dans ce ministère chargé de l'autonomie
vous le savez la crise sanitaire a
particulièrement mobilisé l'ensemble des
acteurs du grand âge et de l'autonomie
cet engagement au nord ces
professionnels il nous oblige aussi
c'est pourquoi dès mon arrivée j'ai tenu
à ce que les aides à domicile qui mérite
d'être mise à l'honneur dans cet
hémicycle bénéficient merci bénéficier
au même titre que ceux qui travaillent
en ehpad d'une prime en lien avec les
conseils départementaux
leur métier est complexe difficile
physiquement psychologiquement
d'autant plus en pleine crise leur
revalorisation prochaine passe aussi par
une amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail
la 5ème branche que nous avons acté
cette création historique lié à la perte
d'autonomie
il nous appartient collectivement de lui
donner corps désormais le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2021 vient posé un premier jalon
avec un périmètre qui reprend le champ
de la scène et ça est complété par
l'allocation d'éducation de l'enfant
handicapé le plfss viendra intégrer des
mesures nouvelles pour 2,5 milliards
d'euros liés notamment au c ur de la
santé rome ne s'est pas fait en un jour
madame la députée je les dis c'est un
premier jalon le laroque de l'autonomie
que j'ouvrirais prochainement permettra
d'associer les acteurs à l'élaboration
de la loi grand âge autonomie que le
président de la république veut voir au
parlement dans les meilleurs délais avec
une présentation au début de l'année
2000 21 comme il l'a précisé à bracieux
en visitant un ehpad
vous avez souligné l'enjeu des
politiques transversales à destination
des personnes âgées personnes en
situation de handicap
je pense notamment aux mesures d'âge j'y
suis sensible
c'est précisément ce qui nous permettra
d'envisager la structuration de cette
cinquième rang
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre
la parole est à monsieur le président
orphelins monsieur le premier ministre
jeudi dernier la commission des lois a
débattu de la proposition de loi sur le
droit de vote à 16 ans portée par paula
forte à coprésidente du groupe écologie
démocratie solidarité
si l'ensemble des groupes a reconnu
l'importance et l'intérêt de ce débat
nous n'avons malheureusement pas eu de
réponse claire de la majorité sur le
fond de cette proposition
d'où ma question au-delà des questions
techniques de calendrier ou de véhicule
législatif
monsieur le premier ministre est ce que
votre gouvernement est pour ou contre
l'abaissement de la majorité électorale
à 16 ans s'il y est favorable
comment souhaite il y travailler dans
les 18 mois qui restent
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
orphelins
le gouvernement partage les
préoccupations que vous avez exprimées
mais ne pense pas à ce stade que
l'abaissement à 16 ans de la majorité
électorale qui je vous le rappelle
supposerait une modification de notre
constitution soit la réponse la plus
adaptée un effet monsieur le député en
effet monsieur le député les jeunes à
partir de 18 ans utilise-t-il
aujourd'hui suffisamment leur droit de
vote
la réponse est non et c'est ce vrai
sujet de l'engagement politique auquel
nous devons ensemble nous attaquer c'est
d'ailleurs ce que cette majorité a
commencé très largement à faire
depuis 2017 ce n'est d'ailleurs pas
étonnant puisque véritable révolution
alors qu'il y avait dans la précédente
législature
quatre députés de moins de 30 ans il y
en a eu 30 qui ont été élus à l'issue
des élections législatives de juin 2010
est ce qu'ils signent une orientation
nous avons le gouvernement et la
majorité le gouvernement et la majorité
ont travaillé sur cette question de
l'engagement notamment sous l'égide du
ministre de l'éducation nationale en
charge de la jeunesse
la citoyenneté monsieur le député se
construit en effet par l'engagement on
ne se découvre pas citoyen on le devient
en ce sens je vous rappelle que le
gouvernement déploie dès l'école
un apprentissage de la citoyenneté par
l'exercice du droit de vote
il renforce la citoyenneté de 145 mille
jeunes chaque année grâce à l'engagement
missions de service civique et bientôt
deux cent mille jeunes supplémentaires
qui seront permis par le plan de relance
je rappelle également à cette assemblée
les nombres dispositif d'engagement qui
ont été mis en place
les jeunes sapeurs pompiers qui implique
38 mille jeunes de 11 à 18 ans les 329
classe de cadets de la sécurité civile
qui accueille plus de 5000 élèves
enfin le gouvernement poursuit la montée
en puissance du service national
universel qui comme vous le savez va
préparer des saisons des saisons nos
jeunes entrés dans la citoyenneté en
somme monsieur le député
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés sur
cette question de l'engagement des
jeunes dans la vie politique comme dans
la vie tout court
il s'agit d'une des priorités de cette
mandature
merci monsieur grévistes savez la peau
remercie monsieur le premier ministre de
ses éléments qui montrent que
effectivement vous êtes contre cette
mesure d'abaissement à 16 ans chaque
opinion se respecte mais on avait
compris linverse de beaucoup de députés
de la majorité qui s'était exprimée la
semaine dernière sur les autres points
ont peu baissé l'âge de la majorité pour
les élections sans toucher à l'âge de la
majorité civile
je vous renverrai le rapport de par la
forte à qui le montrent très clairement
sur le reste les pays qui l'ont mis en
oeuvre récemment les résultats sont très
bons en autriche 80 % de votants sur les
la trancheuse de 18 ans 60% la deuxième
élection et donc il ya des résultats
c'est dommage monsieur le premier
ministre que vous choisissiez de faire
du surplace sur cette mesure là il ya
d'autres pays en europe qui avance et
partout dans le monde les jeunes se
mobilisent sur le terrain dans les
associations vous l'avez dit on peut
aussi les engagés et ne pas rester les
bras croisés
toutes les soirées les sto électorale se
ressemblent et commence tout en disant
il ya trop d'abstention dommage que vous
ne souhaitiez pas allé pour un régler ce
problème là merci le parole de monsieur
eric eric diard mais merci beaucoup sur
le président ma question s'adresse aux
me disait l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre
après l'avoir sans cesse repoussée
emmanuel macron a finalement prononcé
son discours sur le séparatisme le 2
octobre dernier après des mois de
tergiversations le président a en fait
employer les bons mots et clairement
désigné la menace du séparatisme
islamistes ce discours a eu des points
forts mais laisse quelques
interrogations notamment sur le fait de
laisser la formation des imams au
conseil français du culte musulman
perturbé par des divisions internes et
qui a toujours des fondamentalistes en
son sein l'islam radical monsieur le
ministre entre notre quotidien le 25
septembre dernier deux journalistes ont
été grièvement blessés au cours d'une
attaque au hachoir qui visait les
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo
en plein procès des attentats vendredi
cela fait trois ans que nice a mis
statut et de jeunes filles au couteau
sur le parvis de la gare saint charles à
marseille ça me dit cela faisait un an
que michael à pons a tué quatre de ses
collègues au sein même de la préfecture
de police de paris
aujourd'hui nous apprenons que le mot
séparatiste est retirée de l'intitulé de
projet de loi qui devait s'appeler
maintenant projet de loi renforçant la
laïcité et les principes républicains
monsieur le ministre entre le discours
du président de la république et les
actes il y as souvent hélas un écart et
parfois même un fossé
la défense de la laïcité des lots de la
république est un combat fondamental qui
nous interdit de terre et de nier la
réalité de la menace islamiste
monsieur le ministre après les annonces
générale du 2 octobre
pouvez vous nous donner plus de détails
sur ce texte qui sera présenté le 9
décembre
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
diard je connais votre honnêteté
intellectuelle et votre engagement sur
cette question notamment puisque avec
votre collègue de la république en
marche monsieur poule hier vous avez
rendu un rapport qui a notamment permis
de travailler sur le texte de loi que
vous propose du gouvernement sous
l'autorité de monsieur le premier
ministre je voudrais simplement désigné
avez vous quelques points de désaccord
mais qu'ils sont formelles mais vous
conviendrez avec moi
la république ne reconnaît sans aucun
culte ce n'est pas le ministre de
l'intérieur qui va former les imams les
sélectionner et même peut-être
aimeriez-vous que j'écrive la prière du
vendredi mais je ne suis pas tout à fait
sûr que ce soit tout à fait dans mes
compétences institutionnelles
comme les catholiques comme les juifs
comme les protections comme les
orthodoxes les musulmans organise la
religion comme ils le souhaitent
la république n'a pas à s'en mêler à la
condition stricte que cela ne touche ni
landre public ni les exigences minimales
de la vie en société
ni les valeurs de la république nous
faisons confiance à nos représentants du
culte musulman comme d'autres présidents
de la république de sa vie politique
l'ont fait avant le président de la
république actuel permettez moi de
souligner monsieur le président monsieur
le député diar qu'effectivement c'est un
texte important sur lequel nous
souhaitons le plus grand consensus
républicain
même si nous devrions assumer quelques
désaccords peut-être mais c'est un texte
fort annoncé par le président de la
république qui mettra fin il faut bien
le dire monsieur le député à des
décennies de laisser aller convenez avec
moi qui dans les années 80 90 les gens
de notre génération qui est en
responsabilité avait pris ces mesures
nous n'en serions pas là monsieur le
député je l'entends bien monsieur le
ministre juste sur ce sujet les
tergiversations et le en même temps
peuvent être des poisons pour les
français merci la parole quand monsieur
christophe faisait sur ministre cherche
moi vous avez également du temps vous
avez raison monsieur le député on peut
pas faire toujours dû en même temps sur
les questions régaliennes sécurité c'est
pour ça qu'on a du mal à comprendre
comment en même temps peut être contre
les stupéfiants ici et pour la
légalisation du cannabis quand on est
maire d'une commune a l'air
la parole et s'il vous plaît la parole
est à monsieur christophe faisait à lui
seul merci monsieur le président allez-y
se reconnaît dans ma question s'adresse
à l'intérieur monsieur le ministre au
groupe agir ensemble nous avons pris
avec beaucoup de granit et beaucoup de
sérieux
le discours du président de la
république tenus aux mureaux le 2
octobre dernier nous avons été
accueillis et d'allemand avec beaucoup
de bienveillance les déclinaisons
courageuse que vous en avez tiré de
façon très concrète comme l'attend la
grande majorité de nos compatriotes
la loi dont nous allons être appelés à
débattre dans les prochains mois va
prendre à bras le corps des sujets
particulièrement sensibles mais
essentiel pour notre société
la neutralité dans le service public et
parapublic parfois battus en brèche par
la multiplication des salles de prière
et la remise en cause du principe de
mixité
le renforcement des pouvoirs du préfet
pour lutter contre les des vivres dans
certaines piscines dans des
bibliothèques ou vis-à-vis
d'associations auxquelles sont accordé
des subventions publiques
la protection contre la pauvreté et la
polygamie les mariages forcés les
certificat de virginité le droit à
l'héritage des femmes les choses sont
dites avec les mots qui conviennent
selon nous l'école obligatoire à 3 ans
pour tous d'un contrôle renforcé des
lieux de culte
c'est courageux c'est attendu c'est
nécessaire à la cohésion sociale et ça
va dans le bon sens alors bien sûr ça ne
remet en rien en question le travail
remarquable déjà fait par une grande
partie du réseau associatif existant
bien sûr ça ne doit pas vous faire
oublier le rôle crucial que jouent les
services publics et l'éducation
nationale dans la cohésion sociale au
quotidien mais il ne faudrait pas pour
autant négliger le rôle que les forces
de l'ordre de police en particulier
auront à jouer dans ce nouveau
dispositif
vous êtes venu dans l'hérault récemment
monsieur le ministre vous avez pu y
constater qu'elles sont mobilisés sur
les trafics de stupéfiants sur la
sécurisation des quartiers sur la
délinquance des mineurs
or les forces de l'ordre vont avoir à
contribuer à ces missions nouvelles
comment la police et c'est ma question
monsieur le ministre comment la police
intègre rappelle pas sony ce nouveau
dispositif
quel rôle at elle a joué dans ce défi
contre le séparatisme la promotion de la
laïcité et la promotion des principes
républicains
merci monsieur le député la parole de
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur députés 11 et merci pour les
mots d'encouragement du gouvernement sur
le texte de loi que nous présenterons le
9 décembre en conseil des ministres cent
quinze ans jour pour jour après la loi
de séparation des églises et de l'état
décidé par cette même chambre
évidemment vous dire monsieur le député
que toutes les décisions que vous
évoquez qui permettent notamment de
renforcer le contrôle des représentants
de l'état de pouvoir imposer la
neutralité politique et religieuse pour
tous les cultes d'ailleurs pour
l'ensemble de ceux qui concourent parce
que salarié ou parce que contractuels
aux fonctionnaires aux services publics
sont des mesures extrêmement importante
et comme je viens de souligner c'est un
manteau un pouvoir administratif qui
reviendra aux collectivités locales qui
de nombreuses réclament beaucoup de
régions donc que deux collectivités
souhaité mettre en place des chartes
notamment pour imposer le fait qu'on ne
verser plus de subventions publiques
quel que soit une association qui serait
clairement projets it ou contraire aux
valeurs de la république mais aussi
représentants d'états dans son pouvoir
administratif
les forces de l'ordre que vous l'avez
souligné concours de manière parfois
accessoires mais principal dans certains
cas notamment de lutte contre la
radicalisation à faire appliquer les
lois de la république
c'est notamment le cas la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure ou
des renseignements territoriaux qui ont
vu leurs effectifs augmenter de plus
1000 mille policiers qui sont venus
depuis trois ans dans ces deux services
qui continueront à voir une augmentation
d'un projet de finances que vous a
présenté le ministre des comptes publics
c'est aussi le cas bien sûr des
policiers des gendarmes qui accompagnent
ici on est contrôleur de l'éducation
nationale
là les collectivités locales qui font ce
qu'on appelle des contrôles de rp
d'urbanisme pour pouvoir mettre en place
le pouvoir administratif des mères ou de
l'état et cela se fait avant tout je
pense dans un dialogue intelligent avec
les collectivités et avec ceux des
associations qui dort en plus grand
nombre
évidemment respectent les lois de la
république vous voyez monsieur le député
ne s'agit pas principalement d'un sujet
pour les forces de l'ordre mais
accessoirement elles peuvent apporter
leur concours pour sous la contrainte
appliquer la loi la république merci
monsieur le ministre la parole et à
madame cécile untermaier merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre de la
justice par un art un arrêt de janvier
2020 la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a condamné sévèrement la france
pour les conditions inhumaines et
dégradantes de ces établissements
pénitentiaires et le non-respect du
droit à un recours effectif
d'autres requêtes sont pendantes la cour
de cassation a depuis jugé que des
conditions indignes d'accueil pouvait
faire obstacle à la poursuite de la
détention est le 2 octobre 2020 c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui a exigé du
parlement d'ici le 1er mars 2021 une loi
permettant la libération des personnes
placées en détention provisoire dans des
conditions indignes
c'est un moment du droit important pour
nous toutes et tous qui au nom du
principe de dignité
dénonçons depuis des années la
surpopulation carcérale
je crois que dans un autre temps vous en
étiez monsieur le ministre le respect du
principe de dignité nous est ainsi
sévèrement rappelé in ou faute
agir sur tous les fronts par décence et
humanité la surpopulation carcérale
n'est pas une fatalité
les dispositions mises en place dans le
cadre de la crise sanitaire ont montré
leur efficacité et combien le travail du
personnel de surveillance et d'insertion
s'en trouvait d'ailleurs amélioré alors
deux questions monsieur le ministre
envisagez-vous de maintenir voire
d'amplifier le dispositif mis en place
sous le contrôle du juge dans le cadre
de l'état d'urgence permettant d'agir
sur la surpopulation carcérale est ma
deuxième question par ailleurs pouvez
vous nous dire combien de nouvelles
places sont attendus à l'horizon de mars
dans le cadre du plan immobilier des
prisons je vous remercie
merci madame le député là par le tas de
chez eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
députés
madame la députée untermaier vous l'avez
dit j'ai j'ai dénoncé en d'autres temps
les conditions carcérales et je continue
à les dénoncer
sans angélisme car la prison est
nécessaire elle est indispensable mais
il faut aussi prioriser tout ce qui est
susceptible d'aller vers la réinsertion
la prison est aussi criminogène j'ai
naturellement pris connaissance des
arrêts rendus par la cour de cassation
de la décision rendue tout à fait
récemment par le conseil constitutionnel
et bien sûr j'ai demandé à mes services
de travailler activement avant le 1er
mars 2020 qui est le délai fixé par la
haute juridiction
ce travail madame untermaier je le dis
mesdames et messieurs les députés se
fera bien évidemment avec vous il est
intolérable que la france puisse être
encore condamné comme le 30 janvier
dernier
vous venez de le rappeler pour
l'indignité de ces prisons au fond
l'état d'une démocratie se mesure aussi
à l'état de ses prisons
la crise sanitaire a permis une baisse
inédite du nombre de détenus et il faut
impérativement éviter une remontée des
effectifs
j'ai demandé ce matin même aux
procureurs généraux de prioriser tout ce
qui est susceptible d'être autre chose
que la prison c'est à dire les mesures
alternatives
bien sûr chaque fois que c'est possible
et je ne suis pas le ministre du laxisme
j'ai demandé ce matin aux procureurs
généraux d'aller dans ce sens
s'agissant du programme immobilier
puisque c'est votre question la création
de quinze mille nouvelles places oui les
programmes sont engagés il ne s'agit pas
d'un quart serré plus il s'agit d'abord
d'incarcérer mieux et bien sûr dignement
mesdames et messieurs les députés
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame stéphanie hadj et merci
monsieur président ma question s'adresse
à sophie cluzel secrétaire d'état chargé
des personnes handicapées et je tiens à
associer mes collègues mobilisés sur le
sujet madame la ministre
en cette journée nationale des aidants
je tiens à saluer toutes les personnes
qui viennent en aide à leurs parents à
leurs grands-parents ou encore à leur
conjoint avec une totale abnégation et
souvent au détriment de leur propre vie
et de leur santé par la mise en place
récente du congé pour les projets dans
le gouvernement et la majorité
témoignent de leur volonté de les
encourager dans la prise en charge des
services essentiels qu'ils rendent au
quotidien aux personnes en perte
d'autonomie
la caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie
parmi ses missions profondément refondée
dans le cadre de la prochaine loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
charge une variété de dispositifs pour
les accompagner au premier rang desquels
la mise en place des programmes de
formation non professionnels co financé
via une contractualisation avec les
départements et les associations
nationales
au total 18 conventions ont été signées
entre 2009 et 2010 huit ayant pour
objectif la formation au bénéfice de 94
mille d'entre eux toutefois avec les
mêmes la mise en place des congés de
proches des dents une anticipation d'un
accroissement de leurs nombreux semble
nécessaire en conséquence est il prévu
d'étendre un plus grand nombre d dans
l'accès à ces formations
enfin madame la ministre vous avez
installé hier aux côtés de madame
brigitte bourguignon
le comité de suivi pour le premier
anniversaire de la stratégie agir pour
les aidants un volet sera-t-il consacré
aux baluchonnage ce dispositif déjà
utilisé dans les outre mer notamment en
martinique et à la réunion qui permet de
soulager les proches des personnes
dépendantes via l'intervention d'une
tierce personne
je vous remercie merci madame le député
la parole était valable au vik luz elle
se veut dire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
hadja merci pour cette question
cette journée nationale des aidants 10e
journée plus de 10 millions d'aidants
qui s'occupent d'un enfant handicapé
d'un proche malade d'un an dans
personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie 10
millions nous devons aider les aidants
et c'est bien tout l'enjeu de notre
stratégie
ce matin j'étais avec le président de la
république et brigitte macron pour
écouter ces aidants au sein de la
plateforme aux et qui répond justement
au besoin de répit de ces 10 millions
d'aidants nous avons voulu accélérer
parce que la crise nous oblige les
réponses à cette dizaine de personnes en
me mettant en place le numéro le 0 800
363 160 pour une porte d'entrée unique
au besoin de répit aux besoins d'accès
aux soins pendant la crise alors vous
m'interrogez sur la formation oui il
nous faut l'accélérer et nous l'ont dit
ce matin nous allons accélérer à plus de
450 milles et dans cette formation d'ici
ils nous ont dit aussi salué la mise en
place du congé rémunéré pour les
salariés dans depuis le 1er octobre
trois mois d'un bond à tirage vraiment
qu'ils répondent à la conciliation entre
vie sociale et vie professionnelle et
les solutions de répit nous avons trente
mille place de solutions de répit dont
20000 pour les adultes et le
baluchonnage est aussi une solution de
répit nous l'avons salué hier avec la
mise en place du comité de soutien
justement et de suivi avec brigitte
bourguignon
c'est une solution que nous devons
absolument travailler que nous faisons
déjà pourquoi c'est si intéressant parce
qu'une fois pour une fois les dents
reste chez lui et c'est la personne qui
vient chez lui tout simplement ne pas du
tout le perturber dans sa vie
quotidienne et permettre aux aidants de
souffler 1 2 3 jusqu'à cinq jours
nous travaillons à ses expérimentations
c'est une des deux solutions
parmi toutes celles que nous mettons en
place car aider des aidants
c est d un pilier de notre société dans
justement dans cette solidarité
collective je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
mes chers collègues des places se sont
libérées je vous engage donc à vous
éloigner les uns des autres pour éviter
que la trop grande proximité des
contacts ne puisse vous nuire
la parole est à monsieur philippe
benassaya
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
vendredi dernier le présent la
république présenté un plan dit de lutte
contre les séparatismes ce plan a le
mérite de désigner enfin l'ennemi c'est
à dire l'islamisme radical
communautariste et cessionnaires cet
islamisme radical n'a rien à voir avec
l'attachement une spiritualité ou un
héritage culturel tels que des millions
de nos compatriotes musulmans peuvent
vivre le séparatisme islamiste est une
machine de conquête des corps d esprit
des territoires après plusieurs mois
d'attenté
vous allez nous proposer enfin des
outils à travers votre futur projet de
loi renforçant la laïcité et les
principes républicains
il y a toutefois monsieur le premier
ministre un angle mort parmi d'autres
dans ce plan est peut-être dans votre
projet de loi je veux parler des prisons
oui aujourd'hui la prison est devenue à
l'intérieur un accélérateur de
radicalisation et à l'extérieur un
diffuseur de séparatisme 500 détenus le
sont pour des faits en lien avec le
terrorisme islamiste
1500 autres de droit commun sont connus
comme radicaliser selon l'excellent
rapport de mon collègue eric diard et
ses propositions concrètes
autant de menaces en puissance pour les
autres détenus et pour le reste de la
société
quand ils ressortiront le maire de
terrain que j'ai été d'une ville
possédant une maison d'arrêt et surtout
le néo le nouveau député vous alerte sur
l'urgence d'une action forte et
déterminée
si je salue l'augmentation de budget
l'achat de futurs équipements de
brouillage la volonté d'enrayer les
suicides en milieu carcéral
il faut faire plus il faut faire plus
vite contre la surpopulation carcérale
et les cellules insalubres
il faut construire les places promises
contre le séparatisme islamistes qui
menacent directement la vie
des surveillants pénitentiaires à qui je
veux rendre hommage il faut des actes
monsieur le premier ministre
qu'allez vous faire pour lutter contre
le séparatisme islamistes dans les
prisons je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député la parole est à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député peña vous allez vous
allez avoir non seulement des actes mais
des chiffres mais pour le coup de vrais
chiffres parce que ce que vous donnez
sont erronées sans agents
supplémentaires affectés au service des
renseignements pénitentiaire qui
travaille évidemment avec les services
du ministère de l'intérieur
si quartier d'évaluation de la ride et
de la radicalisation 1/7 d'ici la fin de
l'année
quatre établissements pénitentiaires
doté de quartier de prise en charge deux
quartiers dans les mois qui viennent
quatre centres spécialisés à paris
marseille lyon lille
le ministre de l'intérieur et moi même
nous travaillons toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines à l'amélioration des
me casse je me suis pleinement engagée
dans l'amélioration du dispositif actuel
avec monsieur gérald darmanin
voilà ce que nous faisons monsieur le
député
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur alexis corbière
monsieur le premier ministre la france
insoumise et très attaché à la laïcité
à tel point que nous ne comprenons pas
que la loi de 1905 ne soient toujours
pas appliquées sur l'ensemble du
territoire
à tel point que nous dénonçons que le
président de la république accepte
encore d'être chanoine de latran
à tel point que nous condamnons les
nombreux avantages fiscaux qui sa coque
sont accordés aux cultes les nombreuses
subventions publiques aux crèches
confessionnelles et les différents
renoncement au principe nous
désapprouvons enfin votre ambition de se
mêler de l'organisation d'un culte
voilà comment renforcer la laïcité et
les principes républicains
selon le nouveau nom de votre projet de
loi mais il nous semble évident que vous
voulez fabriquer un agenda médiatique où
durant des mois vous répéter des mots
qu'ensuite vous peinez à définir tel le
séparatiste puisque vous l'avez
abandonné dans le titre de votre projet
futur projet de loi
ainsi vous contourner les problèmes
sociaux et sanitaires qui déchire notre
pays en saturant l'opinion d'une
question obsessionnelle l'islam l'islam
l'islam vous voulez lutter contre les
islamistes est bien à jc chaque fois
qu'ils ne respectent pas la loi
on peut exiger autre chose en république
j'affirme ici que les lois actuelles
permettent déjà largement de régler les
problèmes pointés par emmanuel macron
vendredi dernier
vous pouvez fermer actuellement des
écoles clandestines nous se développe le
fanatisme d'ailleurs donnez nous des
chiffres à leur sujet
combien sont-elles réellement contre
lesquels vous ne pourriez agir et
pourquoi tous ces buzz que vous
déclenchez inlassablement dans les
médias les certificats d'allergie au
club contre de virginité nous attendons
à ce sujet des faits des éléments
d'analystes partagé afin de mieux agir
s'il le faut vous voulez agir contre des
séparatistes
et bien voilà en voilà un celui des
riches qui ont leurs propres écoles
leurs cliniques qui refusent l'impôt et
qui font de plus en plus ces cessions
comme le dénonce avec inquiétude le
politologue jérôme fourquet
bref vous les faire reculer le fanatisme
faite pour blesser la république la
santé l'éducation la justice l'égalité
hommes femmes la lutte contre la provôté
contre le chômage la majorité nos
concitoyens
marquant leur part de religion laissez
les fidèles tranquille quand il respecte
la loi mais agissez pleinement pour les
citoyens merci monsieur débuté la parole
à monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le député corbières
si certains ont évoqué le réveil
républicain malheureusement je crains
que vous soyez dans le déni si je devais
reprendre une formule évangélique
je dirais que ce que des oreilles
entende mais c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas
plus sourd que celui qui ne veut pas
écouter
si vous n'avez pas vu monsieur corbières
de là vous êtes élu et le scrutin
uninominal que vous combattez est quand
même quelques avantages celui de vous
mettre normalement au milieu de vos
concitoyens et dans votre
circonscription vous le savez fort bien
on aura l'occasion peut-être tout à
l'heure de se voir alors moi j'ai appris
ma maman mais maman et ma maman n'a pris
a pas montré du doigt ce très très très
heureux quand il est monsieur le
ministre
ça fait sans doute partie de ne pas
montrer du doigt monsieur le député les
exigences minimales de la vie en société
et je vous demande monsieur le député de
m'entendre autant que je vous ai entendu
et sans doute que la démocratie oblige
de votre part un peu de calme lorsqu'on
a un point de vue différent du vôtre
effectivement la situation monsieur le
député est extrêmement grave et jeu mais
je m'excuse je je je ne m'étais je ne
m'excuse pas car si comme le vôtre c'est
le théâte énoncé pendant longtemps
l'opium du peuple
bon soit désormais lié avec un islam au
gauchisme qui détruit la république
voilà la réalité monsieur corbières ce
que nous faisons ce n'est pas simplement
manifestement de gêner quelques
islamistes radicaux mais quand j'entends
vos propos et celle du président
mélenchon je sens qu gêne aussi beaucoup
de votre corps électoral merci monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à madame coralie du boss
est à elle seule s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît merci monsieur le président
pour un sujet qui je l'espère sera trans
partisan sur les bancs de cet hémicycle
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian
monsieur le ministre à l'heure où le
peuple ouïghour subi une répression
terrible au xinjiang
notre jeunesse nous exhorte à ne pas
détourner le regard à sa façon munis de
hashtag de postes instagram notre
jeunesse s'est mobilisée elle n'accepte
pas elle n'accepte pas la violation
organisé par pékin des droits les plus
fondamentaux des peuples louis qu elle
n'accepte pas les atteintes aux droits
des femmes des enfants
les atteintes aux libertés individuelles
les traitements inhumains et dégradants
monsieur le ministre nous avons
conscience de l'engagement du président
de la république et du vôtre dans le
cadre du dialogue franc et direct avec
les autorités chinoises
mais notre jeunesse réclame d'ajouter à
ses relations diplomatiques
la puissance de la parole publique
notamment à l'endroit des acteurs privés
nommant ici dans cet hémicycle ce qui
arrive aux ouïghours nommons les
entreprises qui continuent de sous
traiter aux fournisseurs
usant des répressions ouigours gap
uniqlo et wei notamment comme notre
jeunesse n'acceptons pas porter la voix
de la france des droits de l'homme celle
de la liberté et de la justice
cette parole monsieur le ministre
portant la auprès des entreprises
françaises et européennes qui continuent
à avoir des intérêts dans les 27 usines
de la région
nous voulons qu'elles s'engagent
concrètement à couper tout lien avec les
sous traitants
nous n'acceptons pas de nous chaussée et
nous vêtir dans l'indignité la
maltraitance du travail forcé
monsieur le ministre dans le cadre de
son dialogue direct avec la chine quels
sont les engagements que la france prend
pour apporter son soutien au peuple et
oui gauche pour me jean-yves le drian
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères madame la députée carolyn du
boss c'est pour ali monsieur le ministre
oui c'est l'émotion j'ai eu l'occasion
j'ai eu l'occasion dans cette assemblée
au mois de juillet dernier de faire
valoir l'indignation de la france à
l'égard de ce qui se passe contre la
population ouïghoure et tous les
documents les témoignages que nous avons
sont qui nous parviennent par les
vecteurs de la société civile sur la
situation aux initiales nous font état
de pratiques injustifiable que vous avez
évoqué nous avons condamné fermement le
président de la république s'est exprimé
avec beaucoup de force sur ce sujet
publiquement lors de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies il ya
quelques jours et nous avons nous-mêmes
porter cette situation au niveau
européen puisque ce sujet a été abordé
publiquement devant le président çi lors
du sommet de l'union européenne et de la
chine au courant du mois de septembre et
aujourd'hui nous avons nous sommes
pourvus devant le conseil des droits de
l'homme des nations unies pour que la
condamnation soit porté par le plus
grand nombre d'états y compris madame
coralie du boss par les membres de
l'organisation de la conférence
islamique dans l'immédiat il y a quatre
urgence la première c'est la fermeture
immédiate des camps d'internement
la deuxième c'est le fait qu'il y ait
une visite du haut commissaire des
nations unies madame bachelet sur place
avec des experts en toute transparence
pour vérifier les dires des autorités
chinoises
on croit comprendre que les autorités
chinoises ne sont pas opposées alors
allons-y et mettant toute la
transparence sur cette situation
la troisième vous l'avez évoqué concerne
les entreprises françaises ou
européennes qui ne sont pas aussi
vigilante qu'il le faudrait sur le
respect des droits de l'homme dans des
conditions que vous avez évoquées il
importe qu'elle le fasse et qu'elle le
dise en ce qui concerne la france que
nos entreprises et les sociétés mères
éventuellement soir respectueuse de la
loi de mars 2010 est qu'il impose enfin
il importe aussi que les ouigours en
france soit reconnue et respectée
ce n'est pas une
la parole est à madame laurence dumont
merci monsieur le président j'associe
bien volontiers à ma question régis
juanico député de la loire
monsieur le ministre les entreprises
notamment les pme et les tpe et tous
leurs salariés doivent faire l'objet de
toute notre attention en cette période
particulièrement difficile
pour autant il ne saurait être question
d'aidé des patrons voyous et ça existe
ceux qui profitent de votre ordonnance
covit du 20 mai qui permet de reprendre
sa propre société
après l'avoir placée en liquidation ou
en redressement judiciaire
une reprise qui s'accompagne de
suppressions massives d'emplois et de
l'effacement des dettes
mais comment est-ce possible grâce à
vous grâce au tour de passe-passe de
cette ordonnance penser sans aucun garde
fou un permis officiel de licencier sans
aucune entrave en somme l'actualité des
derniers mois a pointé ce scandale déjà
avec camaïeu et alinéa pour ses
dirigeants sans vergogne et peu
scrupuleux
l'effet d'aubaine était trop tentant le
risque minimal et le bénéfice maximal un
véritable scandale qui continue avec
inteva les dirigeants de ce groupe
américain ont saisi cette opportunité
qu'il n'imaginait même pas dans leur
rêve capitaliste les plus fous il
pourrait ainsi si leur offre était
retenue par le tribunal de commerce
ce vendredi se débarrasser de 169
millions d'euros de dettes chiffres
avancés par mon collègue alain tourret
dans le courrier qu'il vous a adressé
maîtres au chantage plus de 300 salariés
avec en particulier la fermeture du site
de saint dié le site
inteva des sons dans le calvados ne
serait pas à ce stade
menacé par l'offre d'inteva mais pour
combien de temps monsieur le ministre
nous ça nous le savons la crise va durer
l'attraction exercée par cette
ordonnance ne va donc pas s'éteindre
au contraire on peut craindre qu'elles
s'accroissent et soient de plus en plus
utiliser quand et comment pensez-vous m
vu le dispositif ministre délégué chargé
de l'industrie merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés mais madame la députée du monde
merci pour cette question qui va me
permettre de clarifier un certain nombre
de points parce que je crois que
peut-être n'avez-vous pas vous n'êtes
vous pas plonger dans le droit des
entreprises en difficulté
mais effectivement le principe d'une
reprise d'une entreprise en difficulté
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs d'un artisan
d'une tpe ou d'une entreprise un peu
plus structuré c'est précisément de
revoir son échéancier de dette de
discuter avec son ancien son actionnaire
est de faire en sorte de trouver les
efforts de part et d'autre pour d
abandon de dettes et permettre à
l'entreprise de continuer son activité
c'est les fondamentaux de la survie des
entreprises en difficulté parce que le
prêteur prend son risque quand il traite
et qui peut se retrouver dans des
situations difficiles et vous le savez
comme moi parce que vous êtes nombreux à
m'interpeller sur ses bancs pour
demander à ce que les banquiers les
créanciers fasse des efforts
et c'est très exactement ce type de
situation que nous traitons deuxième
élément madame la députée il est faux de
dire que cette ordonnance autorise la
reprise et que ce serait nouveau par un
actionnaire de sa propre entreprise
parce que ça existe depuis bien
longtemps
la seule modification apportée par cette
ordonnance c'est de supprimer dans un
dans un esprit d'efficacité de rapidité
à un moment où nous étions confrontés à
une crise majeure
une étape qui est le fait d'avoir une
ordonnance formalisé par le procureur
près la république auprès du tribunal
ce qui est pas exactement ce que vous
indiquez enfin le troisième élément et
vous le savez c'est que cette ordonnance
elle trouvé une fin le 31 décembre
elisabeth bornes et moi même n'avons
déjà indiqué devant cette assemblée elle
ne sera pas prolongé alors je voudrais
quand même préciser une chose
ce qui nous motive aujourd'hui madame la
députée c'est justement de sauver des
emplois
il n'y a pas d'alternative à certains
situation et certains dossiers et
lorsque vous sauver deux usines je crois
interrogé les salariés parce que ils ont
fait leur choix à paroles est à monsieur
yves déménager merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le garde
des sceaux
vous avez annoncé une augmentation de 8%
du ministère de la justice du budget
dans la tente du débat sur les moyens et
financement de votre souhait je prends
acte de votre annonce
il était temps c d'augmentation nous
permettra peut-être de gagner quelques
places dans le classement européen des
budgets des systèmes judiciaires ou
l'allemagne et les pays bas par exemple
dépensent près du double par habitant
pour leur justice jeudi dépenses mais il
serait plus juste de parler
d'investissement le défi est immense
condamné plus vite faire exécuter toutes
les peines construire des places de
prisons manquantes rénover les plus
indignes d'entre elles lutter contre la
radicalisation en milieu carcéral
traiter enfin les problèmes
psychiatriques de nombreux détenus
développer les peines alternatives miser
sur la réinsertion pour limiter les
récidives augmenter les moyens de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse et
enfin assurer une place une juste place
aux victimes d'un autre système
judiciaire je le redis face à la hausse
des chiffres de la délinquance
face aux agressions de policiers
gendarmes pompiers soignants et lui le
défi est immense
monsieur le ministre je vous pose trois
questions allez vous affecter
prioritairement ses moyens la
construction et à la rénovation de
places de prison ainsi qu'à la
rénovation de tribunaux je pense
notamment à celui de colmar qui en a
bien besoin en bâtiment et en sommes
allés vous affecter prioritairement ses
moyens pour réduire enfin les délais
entre la commission des délits et leurs
sanctions
enfin pour finir allez-vous développer
les moyens donnés aux juges de prononcer
et faire exécuter en plus grand nombre
des condamnations à des travaux
d'intérêts généraux
merci sur collègues la parole de
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice du
président mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député m d'un g vous auriez
presque pu signer à mes côtés ma
première circulaire de politique
générale que j'ai adressée aux
procureurs généraux de notre pays
pourquoi parce que elle couvre tout ce
qui est vos préoccupations
tout ce qui correspond à vos
préoccupations construction de places de
prison je l' ai dit tout à l'heure à
madame le député un terme ailleurs bien
sûr continuation mais également ce qui
concerne l'exécution des peines la
difficulté d'ailleurs dans l'exécution
des peines
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas que les peines
ne sont pas exécutées contrairement à ce
que j'entends parfois elles le sont à
hauteur de 90% 92%
la difficulté c'est qu'elles sont
exécutés de trop tard et je veux passer
d'un tiges qui est exécutée 14 mois
après un travail non rémunéré qui est
exécuté tout de suite jeudi et g10
maintenant aux procureurs généraux qu'il
valait mieux un travail rémunère non
rémunéré tout de suite que deux mois
d'emprisonnement avec sursis dans 18
mois
voilà la philosophie dans laquelle je
veux m'inscrire
s'agissant de la récidive bien sûr que
nous y songeons et je peux vous dire que
nous avons très précisément réparti ce
budget que je l'espère vous vous voterez
entre la justice la pénitentiaire
les services de protection judiciaires
tout le monde tout le monde bénéficie de
ce budget et tout cela recouvre toutes
les préoccupations monsieur le député
qui sont les vôtres
joe breen me croire merci monsieur
monsieur le député oui monsieur le
ministre je souscris à ce que vous avez
dit
reste à mesurer mais j'espère que la
mesure sera extrêmement faible les
différences entre ce que vous dites est
ce que vous ferez et ce qui sera inscrit
dans le projet de loi de finances pour
le budget
merci monsieur ministre bon la parole à
monsieur ludovic mendes merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
je tiens à y associer mes collègues de
la commission des affaires culturelles
et tout particulièrement à une brûlure à
anne christine langues et pierre enrayer
ce vendredi 2 octobre le président de la
république a tenu un discours franc
clair et sans stigmatisation pour
dénoncer les séparatismes de notre
république en appelant à une
mobilisation de toute la nation
un réveil républicain dans nos
territoires
certains citoyens se voient comme les
nouveaux misérables de la république
pour eux demain c'est loin
l'avenir est incertain il souffre d'une
crise d'appartenance collective face à
la république
alors parfois il se réfugie auprès des
personnes qui les comprennent leur
ressemble ne les juge pas et leur
propose un autre cadre où s'installent
souvent un discours identitaire
il nous a fallu comprendre non pas pour
excuser mais pour agir pour arrêter
cette conquête séparatiste le président
a annoncé un projet de loi dont l'école
est un pilier
c'est un sujet primordial l'enfant est
naïf insouciant est en pleine
construction pour l'âge adulte il a
besoin de repères et de modèles si ceux
là sont défaillants on ne cherche que
l'embrigadement pour une cause
fondamentalistes alors nous pouvons que
difficilement les faire revenir une fois
adulte sur le chemin de la république
ainsi dès la rentrée 2021 l'instruction
à l'école sera rendue obligatoire pour
tous dès 3 ans donc l'instruction à
domicile sera strictement limitée
notamment aux impératifs de santé les
écoles hors contrats feront l'objet d'un
encadrement plus renforcée sur le
parcours des personnels le contenu
pédagogique des enseignements et
l'origine des financements à titre
personnel j'espère cohésion nous y
intégrerons le redécoupage des cartes
scolaires pour garantir la mixité
sociale
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
détailler les mesures en faveur de la
protection de l'enfance et notamment sur
les moyens de contrôle de l'instruction
obligatoire et des écoles hors contrats
prévus dans le cas de ce projet de loi
je vous remercie merci chocolate
la parole à monsieur jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
et ludovic mendes je souscris évidemment
à chacun de vos propos et vous avez
raison de placer votre question sous le
signe des droits de l'enfant parce que
en effet ce que nous allons faire c'est
non seulement la protection de la
république
mais c'est aussi tout simplement la
protection des droits de l'enfant et il
est important de dresser un parallèle
entre les deux puisque finalement depuis
ce que fait la république au travers de
l'école de la république c'est non
seulement se consolide et elle-même par
l'école mais aussi augmenter les droits
de l'enfant durant cette législature
vous avez déjà fait une oeuvre
importante
vous avez voté l'instruction obligatoire
à 3 ans vous avez accompagné le
dédoublement des classes de cp et de ce1
et maintenant de grande section de
maternelle qui concerne trois cent vingt
mille enfants parents chaque génération
suivante c'est extrêmement concret c'est
extrêmement sociale c'est extrêmement
protecteur de l'enfant
l'instruction à domicile elle est
finalement quand on regarde les débats
parlementaires de 1882 une forme
d'exception envisagée mais qui en
réalité s'accompagne de mesures pour
protéger les droits de l'enfant
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus en
situation de bien protéger les droits de
l'enfant parce que trop d'enfants sont
conduits vers l'obscurantisme le racisme
l'antisémitisme toutes sortes de
phénomènes que évidemment et la misère
éventuellement en effet qu'ils peuvent
qui peuvent les gaietés donc aujourd'hui
nous devons à la fois lutter contre la
misère et nous devons aussi lutter
contre tous les groupes qui essayent
d'enrôler les enfants et cela se passe
malheureusement très jeunes aujourd'hui
tout à l'heure monsieur alexis corbière
se demandait ce que nous allions faire
en matière de fermeture qui serait
innovants bien oui aujourd'hui c'est
difficile de fermer une structure
scolaire clandestine
demain avec cette loi il y aura des
fermetures administratives de structures
clandestines et cela évidemment sera
protecteur des droits de l'enfant et
puis il y aura en effet la limitation de
l'instruction à domicile pour le
chauffer exceptions notamment en cas de
problèmes de santé
là aussi ce sera protecteur des droits
de l'enfant et donc c'est une loi
offensive pour la république et
offensive pour les droits de l'enfant
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur jean félix acquaviva
merci monsieur le président en cette
journée nationale les proches aidant ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le ministre votre prédécesseur
avait été sensible de la demande
légitime de familles résidentes en corse
qui comptent parmi leurs membres un
enfant atteint d'une maladie grave qui
doit se rendre sur le continent à
marseille nice ou paris pour y recevoir
des soins
photo le chu dans l'île où en l'absence
de la spécialité médicale sur place
lorsque vous êtes un parent qui se
retrouve malheureusement dans le cas
dans ce cas l'assurance maladie prend en
charge automatiquement le biais d'un des
deux parents accompagnants uniquement
lorsque la maladie est grave et
chronique
la présence du deuxième parent devient
indispensable après divers échanges que
nous avons pu avoir aussi bien sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale dans le
cadre du plfss 2020 notamment que lors
de relations directes entre la ministre
d'alors et les associations de parents
comme la marie-do où ils s'aiment et que
je salue medac jacqueline gourault et
agnès buzyn annonce en mars 2019 puis en
novembre 2019 que la prise en charge du
déplacement du deuxième parent par
l'assurance maladie sera effectif par
décret en attendant l'apparition de ce
dernier les frais de déplacement sont
prises en charge temporairement par les
deux caisses de solidarité de
l'assurance maladie de l'île obligeant
les parents à avancer les frais
inhérents
cette situation ne peut perdurer dans la
mesure où ces caisses finance déjà
d'autres actions sociales qui pourront
se voir réduites ou supprimées sur le
long terme
le président de la république à
l'occasion de son déplacement en corse
en septembre dernier annonce la parution
imminente du décret cependant nous
apprenons que le décret à paraître
prendrait en compte uniquement les
mineurs de moins de 16 ans et exclurait
certaines maladies dont la spécialité
pourtant bien absente sur l'île ainsi
les grands engagements pris l'année
dernière par le gouvernement ne serait
pas totalement tenu
si tel est le cas permettez moi monsieur
le ministre de vous exprimer mon profond
désaccord face à ces critères
inacceptable pour les familles
concernées qui le vivre à juste titre
comme une injustice pouvez ou donc nous
assurer monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui
que toutes les familles et tous les
enfants concernés ne seront pas oubliés
par ce décret je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé
monsieur le député je peux vous
confirmer ce que vous avez dit d'abord
me joindre à votre votre constat est une
forme de double peine
avoir un enfant malade et ne pas pouvoir
le faire soigner dans la région dans
laquelle on réside du fait de l'absence
de structures sanitaires adéquates pour
des situations très particulières
et effectivement vous l'avez dit mes
prédécesseurs avaient pris l'engagement
et l'ont mis en place dans un dispositif
extra légale en mars 2010neuf de prise
en charge des frais de transport d'un
deuxième accompagnant là où le droit
commun sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
prévost pour un seul accompagnant en
matière de frais de transport le
président la république vous l'avez dit
également au mois de septembre
lors de son déplacement en corse s'est
engagé à ce que ce dispositif soit
pérennisée et un décret va paraître
permettant de conforter ceux là dans le
droit
ainsi il n'y aura plus de difficultés
rencontrées need avance de frais ce
dispositif monsieur député il concerne
la totalité des mineurs de moins de 16
ans ayant recours à une hospitalisation
et la totalité des mineurs de moins de
16 ans et en ce qu'on appelle en
affection longue durée
la catégorie des affections de longue
durée recouvrant l'écrasante majorité
pour ne pas dire la totalité et au delà
des pathologies qui requièrent des soins
spécialisés qu'on trouverait sur le
continent et qu'on ne trouverait pas
encore si toutefois il y avait encore
des difficultés des situations
extrêmement particulière qui ne
rentraient pas qu'ils ne rentreraient
pas dans une de ces deux catégories
j'ai pris l'engagement et je vous le
confirme que l'ensemble des caisses de
solidarité auquel vous faites allusion
qu'il s'agit se laissent de la scène de
la msa ou celle de la ceppm rentre alors
évidemment en fonction de manière à
épargner toute dépense de transport
inhérentes aux soins de l'enfant que ce
soit pour l'un ou pour les deux parents
l'accompagnant merci monsieur le
ministre sur le député monsieur ministre
merci pour la réponse je crois que le
demande des familles qui ne sont pas
dans le champ qui est pourtant subissent
une double peine mérite un rendez-vous
pour approfondir ces cas particuliers ou
de la caisse d'assurance maladie
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole était valable josiane
corneloup merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
j'étais vendredi dernier aux côtés des
éleveurs d'ovins devant la préfecture de
saône et loire pour exprimer
l'exaspération d'hommes et de femmes
passionnées par leur métier qu'ils
subissent depuis juin
les attaques d'un seul loup qui aura tué
en l'espace de trois mois
cent neuf moutons de race charolaise
j'ai vu un éleveur victime de plusieurs
attaques en larmes devant les derniers
cadavres de vin qui l'avait emmené à
mâcon outre l'anxiété permanente subies
par les éleveurs
la perte financière générée est très
importante car l'indemnisation qui obéit
à un barème national ne couvre
absolument pas le prix d'un nova
charolais à forte valeur ajoutée
cette race est le résultat de longues
années de recherches génétiques de même
l'indemnisation des brebis gravides
ignore les animaux les agneaux à naître
c'est donc au total un manque-à-gagner
injustifiable qui impacte les comptes
d'exploitation des éleveurs la
configuration du bocage charolais très
parcellisé impose un mode d'élevage
dispersées qui interdit toute
cohabitation entre le loup et l'élevage
ovin et cela en dépit des équipements de
protection des troupeaux déjà mis en
place
même si le loup finira je l'espère par
être abattu par les louvetiers le
problème ne sera pas résolu pour autant
le préfet a déjà annoncé que la
saône-et-loire est manifestement sur un
front de colonisation d'autres louent
pourront donc à leur tour investir le
département ce n'est pas aux éleveurs de
modifier leur façon de travailler et de
s'adapter aux comportements des loups
pas plus qu'ils n'ont à construire des
bunkers pour abriter leurs moutons au
nom d'une biodiversité y réfléchit
imposées par l'état par conséquent
monsieur le ministre
allez-vous reconsidérer les dispositions
du plan loup pour que celui ci prenne
enfin en compte les intérêts des
éleveurs et assure la pérennité d'une
économie pastorale à laquelle vous comme
moi sommes très attachés
je vous remercie chaque collègue la
parole à madame barbara pompili ministre
de la transition écologique
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée corneloup c'est une question
difficile et je suis comme vous très
attentive à la situation des éleveurs
j'étais d'ailleurs dans les hautes-alpes
récemment pour rencontrer des éleveurs
qui ont été victimes d'attaqués de loups
et qui le vivent très difficilement et
même au delà de la question financière
c'est c'est une attaque même contre leur
manière de travailler
c'est quelque chose de très angoissant
et il faut que nous soyons à leur côté
pour pouvoir faire face sur la question
du loup n'oublions pas que c'est une
espèce protégée et qui doit le rester
c'est une espèce protégée mon rôle en
tant que ministre de la transition
écologique c'est de faire en sorte que
cette coexistence puisse se passer le
mieux possible
oui le loup est revenu et nous devons
nous y habituer pour nous y habituer on
ne peut pas laisser les éleveurs tout
seul et ça vous avez bien raison face à
ça il y a des engagements qui ont été
pris par l'état effectivement à travers
le plan loup le soutien des éleveurs
aussi à travers la brigade loups de
l'eau fbi qui vient porter main forte
sur le terrain sur la situation
particulière dont vous parlez sur la
saône et loire je suis en lien avec le
préfet qui effectivement m'a fait
remonter les attaques qui ont eu lieu
depuis ces derniers mois
nous travaillons pour soulager des
éleveurs face à leur désarroi et
l'ensemble des mesures d'effarouchement
qui n'ont pas été suffisantes nous ont
amenés à décider et le préfet
coordinateur l'a annoncé a autorisé un
tir de prélèvement pour ce loup
ces tirs sont possibles en dernier
recours mais c'est ici le cas
et donc ce tir a été a été autorisé plus
largement je serai vigilante à ce que
nous puissions appliquées nous mêmes sur
le terrain ce que nous demandons aux
autres ailleurs quand nous demandons
dans à l'international à protéger
l'éléphant d'afrique par exemple qui
fait d'énormes dégâts sur les cultures
nous ne pouvons pas le faire si nous
mêmes nous ne réussissons pas à gérer la
coexistence avec la faune sauvage
mais pour cela les éleveurs qui sont en
première ligne ne peuvent rester seul je
suis à leurs côtés je sais que je
pourrai compter sur vous
merci madame la ministre
la parole d'un monsieur le budget smar
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur à quelques jours de
l'assemblée générale des sapeurs
pompiers de france
un accablant constat s'impose les
violences contre les pompiers sont
toujours en forte augmentation sur
l'ensemble du territoire
à titre d'exemple dans mon département
de loire atlantique
plus d'une centaine de signalements ont
été effectués en 2019 contre seulement
jeu mais seulement entre guillemets
monsieur le ministre
17 en 2010 est une agression tous les
trois jours
sur ces bancs je sais que notre
indignation est unanime c'est violence
qu'elle soit verbale ou physique contre
ces héros du quotidien sont intolérables
nous leur devons des réponses et nous
leur devons des solutions ils risquent
déjà leur vie dans l'exercice de leurs
missions
comment imaginer qu'il puisse également
faire face à des agressions
monsieur le ministre depuis votre
arrivée place beauvau
vous avez pris des mesures fortes pour
soutenir les sapeurs pompiers avec la
revalorisation de la prime de feu c'est
aujourd'hui sur la question de la
protection face aux violences que les
pompiers attendent des actes pour une
plus avoir à se rendre en intervention
la peur au ventre avec la crainte d'être
agressé l'utilisation des caméras piéton
a été une première réponse monsieur le
ministre
existe-t-il d'ores et déjà à bilan de
cette initiative
de plus le taux de condamnation des
personnes inquiétées de violence sur les
pompiers est très bas ce qui peut être
particulièrement décourageant vous en
convenez
comment comptez vous remédier à cette
situation
je vous remercie merci avec la parole de
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur mais je président mesdames
et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député j'espère vous avez
parfaitement raison à quelques jours du
congrès des pompiers ces questions se
posent
mais elle se pose aussi tous les jours
que la république permet aux forces de
l'ordre et bien sûr aux pompiers la
république qu'ils soient volontaires
professionnels qu'ils soient militaires
ou qu'ils soient civils et qui
interviennent dans des circonstances
déjà dramatique de par leur fonction
confronté à la misère confronté à la
détresse
confronté aux difficultés humaines mais
bien sûr face parfois face souvent
désormais à des agressions qu'elles
soient orale tout à fait inacceptable
physique et qui parfois parfois blessent
et tuent
j'ai des moments ma nomination rendu
visite aux sapeurs pompiers aient eu
l'occasion plusieurs fois depuis les
quatre mois que je suis mise de
l'intérieur sous l'autorité de monsieur
le premier ministre de porter plainte
systématiquement monsieur le député pas
simplement en aidant le pompier blessé
ou agressés mais au nom de l'état contre
les personnes qui manifestement ne
respecte pas le b à ba de la civilité et
de la république et de ses valeurs
j'ai donc accepté avec les sports
oublier toutes les organisations
syndicales que j'ai longuement reçu et
je me rendrai moi même au congrès des
sapeurs pompiers et le président de la
république se rendra au congrès des
sapeurs-pompiers de pouvoir accentuer à
protection que nous leur devons d'abord
dans la protection fonctionnelle pour
les aider notamment juridiquement lors
ce qu'ils ont ensemble de difficultés
que doivent faire valoir leurs droits
deuxièmement prenant une instruction aux
préfets pour organiser de manière
méthodique sur chacun des territoires de
la république la protection des forces
de l'ordre des policiers des gendarmes
lorsqu'ils doivent intervenir c'est
notamment ce qui s'est passé à
rillieux-la-pape où cette protection a
fonctionné et au lac ou lequel tout ça
pour oublier d'abord passé au
commissariat pour aller éteindre un
incendie de véhicule
troisième en mettant les caméras par ce
manque et on met sur les véhicules
la loi devrait le permettre si vous la
beauté monsieur d'écouté afin d'aider la
justice à mieux condamner les fauteurs
de troubles merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur alain bruneel
monsieur monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé le personnel
soignant est épuisée par ses longs mois
de lutte pour sauver des vies mais aussi
très affectés par les nombreux décès
touchant les patients et leur profession
depuis plusieurs années les plans
annuels d'économies sont affaiblis
fortement la situation des hôpitaux en
2009 2019
une fois de plus froids 1400 lits ont
été supprimés malgré les cris d' alerte
des personnels soignants et bien avant
le coronavirus les hôpitaux ont été
contraints de réduire leurs capacités
d'accueil
la crise sanitaire actuelle a
malheureusement aggravée les faiblesses
de notre système hospitalier
en mars dernier malgré des conditions de
travail parfois catastrophiques
le personnel a dû une nouvelle fois
faire face et être inventifs
monsieur le ministre vous ne répondez
aucunement à l'état d'urgence dans un
contexte où les scientifiques alertent
sur une éventuelle seconde vague vous ne
changez pas de cap
monsieur le ministre je vous le rappelle
le personnel est à bout de souffle
la première vague a démontré la limite
des ressources humaines et matérielles
aucune leçon a été retenue manque criant
de lits et plus particulièrement en
réanimation manque de moyens humains et
matériels mais aussi des protections
toujours en nombre limité et à la veille
de l'hiver
la crainte que le vaccin anti grippe ne
soit pas en nombre suffisant pour ne
citer que celui là
les soignants n'ont plus confiance ils
ont tout donné ils ont été volontaires
et ils ne veulent plus revivre la
situation de la première vague
la confiance est rompue également par
les oubliés du ségur monsieur luministe
entendez-vous ses héros pour clamer
mobilisés pour sauver l'hôpital public
qui sont une nouvelle fois dans la rue
le 15 octobre
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier verront ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député je peux partager votre inquiétude
et des constats que vous avez fait sur
l'hôpital public s'agissant des années
pour ne pas dire les décennies
précédentes en manière en matière de
suppressions de lits suppressions de
postes réduction des moyens pour
l'hôpital et notamment l'hôpital public
ça on peut le partager monsieur le
député parcours de votre dans votre dans
votre question j'aurais presque tendance
à oublier que nous avons eu la signature
d'un accord majoritaire
ça n'était pas arrivé non plus depuis
des années dans notre pays
dans l'ensemble des corps professionnels
de l'hôpital public notamment force
ouvrière la cfdt et l'unsa qui ont signé
un accord du ségur pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils ont signé cet accord du ségur
parce qu'il apporte de l'oxygène comme
jamais l'hôpital en avait connu vous
allez devoir bientôt voter en tout cas
vous allez pouvoir bientôt voter des
mesures et monsieur le député brunel je
suis sûr que vous allez en beauté
plusieurs je suis si vous allez voter
les 8 milliards d'euros de
revalorisation des salaires pour 1.6
million de salariés soignants dans notre
pays
pour 85% des femmes vous allez le voter
et mathieu brunelle je suis sûr vous
allez voter la reprise de dette de 13
milliards d'euros pour l'ensemble des
hôpitaux
c'est un tiers de la dette des hôpitaux
qui s'était creusé depuis 20 ans vous
allez voter monsieur brunel les 6
milliards d'euros d'investissement du
plan de france relance qui vont
permettre de développer tant dans les
ehpad que dans l'hôpital quand domicile
qu'en médecine de ville
des structures modernes et numérisés
vous allez le voter monsieur brunel
l'ouverture de 4000 lits dans l'ensemble
des hôpitaux publics de notre pays
vous allez le voter monsieur brunel le
renfort de 15000 postes créés
supplémentaires dans l'ensemble des
hôpitaux
je suis sûr que vous allez le voter
monsieur brunel accompagner nous on peut
faire le constat que la situation
n'était pas glorieuses on peut faire
ensemble constat que la situation est
tendue pour le soignant les soutenir et
les accompagner mais pas leur faire peur
quand vous dites monsieur brunel qu'il
n'y aura pas de vaccins pour tous les
soignants il y aura des vaccins pour
tous les soignants la campagne de
prévention de la grippe commencera le 13
octobre
et je profite des dernières secondes
pour encourager tous les soignants de ce
pays à l'hôpital en ville en ehpad à se
faire vacciner contre la grippe c'est
une protection pour eux mêmes mais
surtout pour les personnes dont ils
prennent soin au quotidien
merci monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre je vous ai écoutés mais il n'y
a toujours pas de réponse à l'état
d'urgence
je vous demande de vous sortir de votre
bulle je veux demande de vous sortir vos
certitudes je demande d'écouter les
soignants qui se bat jamais vous
répondez aux questions vous répondez pas
le taire d'urgence ya un fossé qui se
collent bien vague se collent entre vos
déclarations et l'intérim monsieur le
député la parole est à madame nicole
trice merci ma question s'adresse à
madame pas guéri lâché le ministre
délégué à l'industrie et j'associe à ma
question mes collègues députés du
département et notamment hélène magnier
et christophe arend madame la ministre
en annonçant subitement le 3 juillet
dernier la vente de son site de
production de smart à hambach
le groupe daimler a plongé dans
l'incertitude l'avenir de ses salariés
et de leur famille du site industriel et
de tout le bassin d'emploi qui en dépend
ce sont quinze mille cinq cents pardon
femmes et hommes dont plusieurs
centaines de sous-traitants qui
travaillent tous les jours
1500 femmes des hommes avec des
compétences de haut niveau qui font la
renommée de smartville smartville c'est
l'un des centres de production
automobile les plus modernes qui soit
c'est un symbole de réussite de la
coopération franco allemande c'est la
vitrine industrielle de la moselle et du
savoir faire français
depuis cette annonce vous êtes
immédiatement mobilisé avec vos équipes
dès juillet vous êtes tenus sur le site
à la rencontre des salariés des élus du
territoire avec un seul objectif le
maintien de l'emploi y compris pour les
sous traitants et est la recherche d'un
repreneur avec un projet industriel
solide
je tiens à saluer votre mobilisation
constante et l'énergie que vous déployez
pour que le site et surtout pour que les
1500 femmes et hommes est un avenir
professionnel
je remercie le maire de hambach et le
président de la communauté d'agglo pour
leur appui auprès de la population
locale et moi je continuerai avec mes
collègues et les élus locaux à me faire
le relais des préoccupations des
salariés dans l'esprit collectif et
trans partis
ans qui nous a mis je tiens surtout à
saluer et à rendre hommage à la dignité
des salariés et de leurs représentants
syndicaux qui ont eu dès le début
l'intelligence collective de former une
intersyndicale solidaire qui ont su
revendiqué dans la dignité sans jamais
mettre le site en péril
c'est aussi par leur action que des
solutions sont aujourd'hui possibles
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
faire un point d'étape à date sur
l'avenir du site dambach suite à notre
réunion de ce matin je vous remercie
merci va débuter madame agnès pannier
rennais ministre délégué chargé de lundi
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
trice merci de montrer par cette
question l'intérêt vous manifestez pour
ce site
un intérêt exigent un intérêt constant
avec vos deux collègues les députés
hélène magnier christophe arendt
je mesure l'émotion et l'inquiétude des
1500 hommes et femmes sous traitants aux
salariés de daimler qui ont appris le 3
juillet dernier la fermeture de ce site
annoncée par des meneurs j'ai
immédiatement fait connaître à la
direction de daimler que je souhaitais
qu'on travaille sur une solution
alternative est une solution de reprise
c'est ce que nous avons fait ensemble et
vous avez raison de souligner le grand
engagement des organisations syndicales
qui ont su s'organiser en intersyndicale
et qui ou un friche et afficher un front
uni unis mais exigeants face à la
direction de daimler et je crois pouvoir
dire que nous avons aujourd'hui un
dialogue constructif et exigeant avec
des moeurs avec l'appui d'un cabinet
conseil que j'ai mandaté le cabinet
roland berger requis à restituer ses
travaux aujourd'hui devant les élus
locaux fortement impliqué dans ce
dossier est devant les organisations
syndicales nous sommes en passe
d'obtenir des avancées significatives je
pense notamment au report de l'arrêt de
la production de la smart qui était
initialement prévue en 2022 et qui
pourrait être repoussé en 2024
je pense à la confirmation de la
production de certaines pièces par des
meneurs sur ce site je pense à l'intérêt
d'un groupe
industriel sérieux pour la reprise et le
développement de ce site sur un nouveau
véhicule
nous allons continuer ce travail en
grande proximité est en confiance avec
les élus du territoire avec les
représentants du personnel et les sous
traitants pour finaliser une solution
obtenir le maximum de garanties pour le
site et pour chaque salarié
vous l'avez compris ma boussole c'est
l'emploi et la préservation des savoir
faire industriels
merci madame la ministre la parole de
monsieur robert therry monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
mes chers collègues gamme la plus grande
entreprise de france souffre vous la
connaissez nous la connaissons tous
ce sont nos artisans de commerçants les
pme ainsi que certaines professions
libérales qui sont au coeur du
développement économique de nos
territoires
bien entendu votre gouvernement a mis en
place des dispositifs de soutien
indispensable
le chômage partiel qui offre une bulle
d'oxygène mais qui ne peut rester que
temporaire le prêt garanti par l'état
certes mais comment faire pour le
rembourser compte tenu de l'arrêt
partielle voire totale des activités
depuis le mois de mars
je pense aussi aux reports de loyer pour
quelques mois
mais quid de ceux qu'ils remboursent des
crédits
les charges de fonctionnement elles ne
sont pas reportées et bien sûr pas de
report et aucune annulation même partiel
des taxes foncières pour la période où
l'activité a cessé sans activité les
pertes d'exploitation sont telles que de
nombreuses tpe seront incapables de
rembourser loyer emprunts accumulés et
charges même après le report pour
certaines elles sont étranglés par ce
mur de dettes qui grossit de jour en
jour avec les députés les républicains
nous demandons depuis des mois des
annulations de charges beaucoup plus
massive pour les tpe et les pme
cela doit être la priorité dans vos
choix de dépenses publiques
sans ces annulations de charge
vous préparez des dépôts de bilan et des
faillites en cascade
êtes-vous donc prêt à engager deux plus
fortes
annulation de charge par ailleurs
monsieur le ministre les aides que vous
proposez le sont sous condition d'un
chiffre d'affaires maximale mais en
aucun cas le bénéfice qui est réellement
touché n'est pris en compte
c'est une importance capitale monsieur
nice pour le bien de ses acteurs
pouvions revenir sur ce critère et au
lieu du chiffre d'affaires prendre
l'exercice le bénéfice réalisé la parole
à monsieur alain griset ministre délégué
chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député terry merci d'abord
de rappeler ce beau slogan c'était
artisanat première entreprise de france
les artisans les commerçants les
professionnels libéraux les pme sont au
coeur de l'action qu'a menées le
gouvernement depuis le confinement
je crois pouvoir dire que la france a
été le pays au monde qui a mis en place
ces dispositifs les plus adaptés en
moyens en entend pour ces entreprises
néanmoins je sais bien qu'il y à
beaucoup d'entreprises sur lesquels il
ya des difficultés qui restent
vous avez cité les loyers c'est vrai et
nous y travaillons et bruno le maire par
ailleurs au fur et à mesure de l'avancée
de la pandémie
nous travaillons sur des secteurs dont
nous savons qu'ils encore des
difficultés
nous avons pris des décisions et lorsque
les restaurateurs ont été fermés sur les
entreprises qui ont été obligés de
fermer par décision de l'état nous avons
passé le fonds de solidarité de 1500 à
10000 euros pour compenser la perte de
recettes tout ça je veux dire concours
accompagner les entreprises à essayer de
leur faire passer ce moment de crise qui
est douloureux et nous adaptons nos
politiques au fur et à mesure des
besoins
permettez-moi néanmoins de signaler que
nous le faisons en essayant de respecter
au mieux les problèmes budgétaires vous
connaissez les difficultés et du budget
et naturellement nous comptons sur votre
soutien pour nous permettre
de comprendre qu' on ne peut pas non
plus aller au delà de ce qu'on a fait
qui est déjà beaucoup
néanmoins tout un compagnon les
entreprises en difficulté merci monsieur
le ministre la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue